[Music]
if you plucked people from all across
the country and said we have a farm the
image that they have of who's that
farmer
would not be kristen leach
[Music]
my name is kristen leach and i'm a
farmer in winters california
and i grow predominantly korean and east
asian herbs and vegetables
i was born in tegu korea
i was adopted as an infant i grew up on
long island in new york
the regional cuisine of long island is
pizza and bagels so that's what i was
just sort of raised on
i just had never really explored korean
heritage but i did get curious about the
food
oh wait this is a really good
little one i worked on organic farms
when i was a teenager
and so i just thought like oh i know how
to grow plants maybe i should grow some
of these plants from korea just to
better understand this place where i'm
from
i
went back to korea for the first time
since i left
i spent just like three weeks traveling
around and was learning from all of
these farmers and visiting different
farms
it felt like a pretty profound way to
actually engage with identity
because it answered for me a sense of
what place i could find within like a
bigger story of korean history
[Music]
i practice a style of farming that's
referred to as natural farming in korea
and japan
everything on the farm has grown
organically
and essentially it's the way just like
peasant subsistence farmers farm
some of the heritage crops that we focus
on here are the korean sesame leaf
the flavor is kind of licoricey
and minty
chame korean melon
is like somewhere between like a
cucumber and melon in flavor it's really
really crunchy
chili peppers a really beloved staple
and japanese eggplant just a small
baseball sized eggplant it's super dense
and really creamy
[Music]
three times a week i'll usually head to
the bay to make a delivery
namugaji is a restaurant in the mission
district in san francisco
all of the produce goes directly to
their restaurant
and their chefs and cooks figure out how
to kind of design a menu around it
my name is dennis lee i'm the chef and
owner of non mugaji in san francisco
[Music]
right now we're doing a really nice
simple grilled eggplant dish with a
really heavy dusting of minced perilla
we're doing a nice melon salad right now
with watermelon and korean melon we have
a chili oil that we serve with our ramen
that has korean chilies from the farm
it's a restaurant that's operated by
korean americans so you see that in what
we do
the way that our relationship works with
kristin is totally unique because it's
tied to who she is
to be able to support an asian woman
and co-create a platform to express
ourselves and share a story with people
that's pretty special
the food that dennis is making allows
itself to just be really original and it
doesn't feel like it's trying to just
reproduce
a mold of what is korean or what is
asian american
i'm learning about like my lineage i'm
trying to figure out a sense of
belonging
the experience of adoption is so
complicated i feel really grateful to
have farming be the way that i interact
with my culture
[Music]